- [Voiceover] This episode
of CC: Social Scene
is based on your suggestion
for odd couples on a date.
- Let's face it,
online dating is tough.
Today's dating apps
use an algorithm
that sets you up with people
you're compatible with,
or most alike.
Dating yourself?
There's no fun in
that, I've done it.
That's why we've
launched OppSit.
The app that works off
of a simple premise.
Opposites attract.
OppSit sets you up with someone
you don't think
you'll get along with.
Skeptical?
I'll let the results
speak for themselves.
- As an environmentalist
and eco activist,
I never thought I'd
be set up with Dale.
- You know,
I never thought I'd fall for
some tree-hugging earthy chick,
but, after one date,
I struck oil (laughs).
- I'm a burglar,
but when it came to love, I
just couldn't crack that safe.
Who'da thought the
most compatible people
would be so incompatible?
- That's why OppSit's so great.
He's my prime suspect
for love.
(giggles)
- I'm busted.
- A butcher and a vegan.
A dog person and a cat person.
A lawyer and virtually
anybody else.
Even a hipster and gluten.
OppSit will set you up.
Who knows?
Your greatest nemesis may
be the love of your life.
(whale song)
There she blows.
OppSit.
'Cause you just
might find romance
where you least expect it.
- Ow.
- [Voiceover] Join
the conversation now
with #CCSocialScene.
Tell us what can go wrong
on a hike without GPS
and we might write it
into our next sketch.
Presented by Redd's Apple Ale.
Crisp like an apple,
brewed like a beer.